would you rather get proposed to at a  baseball game or at a cracker barrel  cracker barrel i can't the the idea of  getting proposed in public like that  terrifies me like in public too yeah but  like it's probably a little bit like  quieter less people like in front of  that many people i'm just saying you  don't have a cracker for yourself that's  that's true if you're proposing to me at  a cracker barrel  we  we're gonna get divorced because some  somebody didn't understand what i was  looking for but you're okay with like on  the jumbotron what do you say alex in my  mind okay so at the baseball game  there's an opportunity that maybe we're  on the field afterwards or in a suite or  something  it's like the seventh inning stretch  like god i'm mad either way then yeah  then if it's the seventh inning stretch  and i'm on the jumbotron it's cracker  barrel